hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey I'm Andrew Gordon we are
gonna watch this second trailer for
spider-man far from home even though the
Russo brothers said that the spoiler ban
is you know this the second Monday after
endgame releases before we go into this
I do want to say thank you to everyone
who has been downloading and following
us on the Stardust app over there with
you 30 second reaction reviews for any
film TV show and or trailer sometimes we
do micro scratches as well then posting
daily with load for you guys to go
follow us today the whole thing is
completely free to download and use
follow us and Andrew from movie source
channel thanks for being here today
buddy horse man let's get into this
despite America far from home trailer is
about to play but if you haven't seen
Avengers endgame yet stop watching
because there's some serious spoilers
about to come up all right I guess we're
gonna talk about
yeah I don't think Tony would have done
what he did if he didn't know that you
were gonna be here after he was gone
[Music]
nice
you sent Nick Fury to voicemail I gotta
go you do not you're a very difficult
person to contact
spider-man is just another house
snap to our home without dementia to do
you're coming with us
[Music]
Wow you want to step up
Hellfire
[Music]
we just got our tickets guys I just got
our tickets it was much harder than
beginning Avengers end game tickets men
I know that's one thing to have like
spoilers about endgame in here it's
another thing to have just you know but
it is Sony we know how they roll yeah
let's watch it one more time before we
talk about it I get we gotta watch this
part this is my support oh yeah I hope
this trailers in the theatre's never
leave the theater get more popcorn
looks like how John looks in the morning
that's cool that seems to be a common
theme in this trailer and being the next
iron may have taken up the mantle of me
then I rest
I demand yeah Iron Man shadow see flash
content that Tony's funeral
yeah it's like Mission Possible fallout
from the air elementals I haven't a
couple of suspicions about this whole
multiverse thing this is like that
ant-man bit I now called The Avengers
cute I really like how the marketing is
trying to sell us on Mysterio being a
hero
[Music]
you want to step up not I love that
stealth suit
that's a great ratio and I love Michael
Giacchino's score on how it has kind of
an espionage so they're like
transitioning Peter to take up the
mantle of the iron man position and
happy does not want to be another one
working for but instead it wants to be
partners I'm working with and I really
like the inclusion of happy in this
trailer this whole thing with Quinn and
Becca's Mysterio the concept of talking
about multiverse the multiverse you guys
gonna watch the one but talking about
the multiverse and that's where he's
from it just seems like it could be some
science fiction backstory that Quentin
Beck has made up or himself you know I
mean it could it could be linking ins
maybe since with Sony so it could be
linking in some way to something like
spider-man into the spider verse and the
snap has created something like that but
I really think they're really trying to
sell this on no mystery is a good guy
mysterious a good guy but like I just
don't buy it you know yeah I mean I like
that they kind of have a mentorship
aspect at least that they're hinting out
in this trailer when they're talking in
the pub or whatever that is you know
like what do you really want Peter you
know like I want to tell the girl I like
the deliverance stuff I feel like that
could lead to a very personal conflict
when the drop finally comes the yeah
according yeah Lee isn't a very good guy
at the end of the day I just want to say
that I love this trailer 3,000 and also
want to say yeah I mean Quinton Beck
he's in the comics he's a visual special
effects and a stuntman so yeah he knows
his hand and combat I kind of feel like
I'm getting the syndrom vibe from The
Incredibles where like he's creating
these illusions and these things and
it's like you know to make himself look
like a hero and get the glory that he
feels he deserves and I do like that
mentor aspect that you were talking
about cuz when that bomb does drop that
he really isn't a good guy it's gonna
feel like a back stabbing to Peter
Parker and like you know because he's
kinda I mean looking for a little bit of
a mentor after what happened with Tony
you know yeah Iron Man so like you know
just to see like huh I finally found
another mentor and like know a guy
shooting for our trailer breakdown
because there's some information in here
that
I'm gonna be processing a little bit
before we film that like the idea
especially the idea of like a lot of
this following in the Iron Man image I
know they're not trying to make him Iron
Man but you know like Iron Man's glass
there's a lot of like I'm okay I'm
totally 100% on board for the grieving
of the loss of Tony Stark in this film
especially since it's the one falling up
and game remember when the homecoming
came out a lot of people were kind of
worried like is this gonna be an Iron
Man movie and it wasn't year I'm like
well I really want to make sure we're
moving past that at this point right now
yeah it looks like a really fun really
cool movie and I'm excited for
everything involved in it this is my one
big nipping and that could be Peter
Parker's arc in the film he's gotta move
like you as much as he loves Tony and
wants to grieve for him like that
reimburses back to Captain America's
line and like some of us don't
arrghh must go on right us well I mean
yeah what do you guys think of the
trailer if you like it least it's coming
too soon you think it's kind of weird
that releases oh and before this video
is over I would like to give a patron
today shout out to a lovely lady named
Brianna Davidson I have gotten to know
this woman so well she is just like
every woman I've ever encountered in my
life I sent her a message
she doesn't send me a message back I
love that she pledged to have a shout
out in one of our videos I don't know if
she notices this but we usually give
shout outs based off getting to know you
and I messaged her days ago and now here
I am giving a shout out to her just
trying to get your attention Brianna I
want you to just get back to me I want
to get to know you so I can give you a
proper shout out and hopefully on one of
our bigger reactions this month you will
finally give me the message Jon deserves
because he reads all my messages text
messages included anyway guys what you
think of this spider-man comment below
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click the notification bell go
ahead and download and follow us on the
start us up as well as follow Andrew on
the movie source channel keep a look out
for our trailer breakdown